[Applaudissements]
jeudi vous savez que je suis très très
très ému de recevoir michel polnareff
michel quoi déjà déjà un cadeau pour moi
michel en tant que michel polnareff et
comme j'ai remarqué que tu avais montré
son postérieur très souvent quelque
chose en commun
oui c'est en tant que michel polnareff
je voudrais te décoré donne ça me fait
chevalier de la ré publique
c'est ce qu'est une bonne barca ce soir
lors d'un atelier relais qui vient de me
dire qu'est ce qui m'a dit est ce qu'une
bonne barca ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
michel je vous aime trop bien sûr alors
ce soir c'est dark assure d'arcade
michel barka et on fait des dar k et
débarque à zéro race rare que des dards
cas c'est baba on va papa voilà comme ça
si à ses débuts comme au café démarre
exactement ont fait que des dark avec
michel polnareff